la bandera de ecuador ondea en jerusalén
oeste ante la primera visita en la
historia de un presidente ecuatoriano al
estado de israel
la agenda de tres días de guillermo
lasso tiene un fuerte vínculo con la
crisis carcelaria en el país andino cuyo
más reciente motín en la prisión del
santo domingo- dejó más de 40 internos
muertos en este contexto su mayor
interés es trasladar herramientas de
seguridad y ciberseguridad israelíes de
ahí que su primer encuentro haya sido
con iain la principal empresa israelí de
defensa este gesto de ecuador- acudiendo
a israel por seguridad no es nuevo ya
que durante el mandato de lenin moreno
fuerzas de élite ecuatorianas recibieron
formación israelí y existió una
asistencia para combatir ataques
informáticos tras el fin del asilo del
fundador de wikileaks julian assange la
firma de un posible tratado de libre
comercio y la apertura de una oficina de
innovación de ecuador en la universidad
hebrea componen las otras aristas de
este viaje con el que laso no sólo sigue
el acercamiento a israel emprendido por
lenin moreno sino que apunta a una
inédita proyección de las relaciones
bilaterales en este sentido también está
previsto que ela se reúna con presidente
israelí yitzhak herzog y el primer
ministro talibán en un escenario
impensable durante los dos gobiernos de
rafael correa mucho más crítico de
israel por su trato a los palestinos en
ese sentido también cabe recordar que
ecuador fue uno de los 33 países en
apoyar el plan de la1 de partición de
palestina en 1947